[Music]
all right switching gears take a look at
this this is what the 35w bridge will
look like again tomorrow mndot planning
once again to light the bridge royal
blue and yellow in honor and celebration
of world war is over now
hold on it's not about ukraine it's
fixed it is it's world down syndrome day
because we're all retards for being
involved in it
hold on march 21st date is significant
because down syndrome is caused when a
person has three copies of the 21st
chromosome so it's like in multiplicity
when you made a copy of a copy and that
one was kind of weird and then i'm
trying the guardian angel i like pizza i
like it see yeah they became a guardian
angel and he was protecting the streets
of philly and he was banging what's the
chick from groundhog day
uh andy mcdowell andy oh handy mcdowell
should we give you one of these
imagine such a thing paul yeah you got
any gum
so hold on hold on
which came first
ukraine or world down syndrome day
and as a country who's probably ukraine
i would think the ukraine by the way
soon
um fun fact i don't know i'm older than
ukraine so the importance of the day
so ukraine stole their colors from the
downies yeah now they won't let the
colors leave on the bus
now we go live to a woman who looks like
she yells at you in stores for not
wearing your mask oh god she does an
executive also she just took a mask off
because she has the mask line over her
nose
director of the down syndrome
association now we go live to a woman
who looks like she takes photographs of
people not wearing masks in their own
car by themselves and post them to
facebook good morning sarah thank you
for joining us it's always a wall of
text it's always a long wall of text
hi
hi thanks for having me it sounds like
some activity some things are going on
tell us what you have planned for today
yeah so we made balloons uh yellow and
blue balloons so
that makes up for all the nazis and the
tortures and the eliminating political
parties and all that stuff but it's
world down syndrome day
yeah so today at the sheridan in
bloomington we well
excuse me i didn't realize they were
going to be at the sheridan convention
center
have our world down syndrome day party
this is actually one of the we have to
be out by five though because there's an
a meeting in this room later i'm pretty
sure someone with down syndrome blew up
those balloons some of them are not
blowing up all the way first things that
we had to cancel in time all i know is a
minute one of those balloons pops that
whole [ __ ] place is gonna clear out
screaming
and four four people with down syndrome
killed today stampede world down
syndrome
super excited to be back together one of
the best parts is is that we're using
the yellow and the blue balloons because
people with down syndrome are much
easier to explain why we're in this war
and honestly they just kind of accept it
as long as you know they do they're
given their juice box they do get
stampeded it's called running of the
drools
2022 to celebrate at this new awesome
donated location
a conference center in a sheridan
to make this class look at the carpet
the carpet is definitely [ __ ] old
hotel carpet so we expect about 500
people between a morning and a half
marbles
how much come do you think is in hotel
carpets a lot right it's got to be a lot
to come in the conference in the carpet
of a [ __ ] room of a hotel oh it's got
to be a lot of come i always come and
conference i try not to think about it i
think about it all the time
that's all i think i really don't like
thinking about people just
well i don't know why people are just
recklessly shooting ropes all over their
hotel room i feel like that's they can
because they can and they will and it's
not their house you've never actually
come on a carpet we've been with the
chicken hotel definitely sure i'm not
saying that you're jerking off on the
carpet
but i'm saying that some cum's going to
dribble on the carpet
but i mean how far are you coming i
don't first i generally have sex in the
bed number one don't can't change me
let's start with that okay number two
the bed also has a lot of [ __ ] in it
yeah but they wash the sheets yeah they
watch the mattresses it seeps through
the paper and seats you're going to hate
hotels that's why i don't know state
hotels that have paper thin sheets sure
i'll have you know
i stayed airbnb's that have paper thin
sheets
that last time yeah
normally no normally they're comfortable
but the last time was like here have one
ply toilet paper to sleep under and i'd
be like can i just sleep with your
newspaper no that's why motels like
motel 6 have switched to hardwood floors
i bet yeah i think you're going to clean
off the [ __ ] but yeah i'm 38 my
testosterone levels aren't as high as
they used to be so i can't fire come all
the way across the hotel bed anyway even
if i wanted to number one they can be if
you wanted to
i know a guy i won't say his name today
nice and it sounds like all ages
well
okay yes also yes alex
okay stop you look like a great uh photo
spot
can you pan over to see all the sad
people drinking lukewarm coffee in the
corner i want to see the rest of the
room
but at a low level because they did
donate uh it's the conference room let's
not get out of control you're hearing it
from the wedding in the oh you're right
next door
through the partition the one they close
them no they do like the old gyms in
high school they would split it off the
two half court games
all right time for singles games all the
single people get up here we're gonna
pop balloons on penises or whatever
they don't they pan and there's just
like two down syndrome kids there
that's why they're they're so focused
hey down syndrome relationships are
patreon content we don't talk about
those here photo spot to uh you know put
on your prop those are just normal
glasses that down syndrome kids have to
wear on the kind of the size of their
big heads
what i'm thinking is
hear me out
[ __ ] jiminy glitch glasses she's
[ __ ] wearing the people at moderna
mm-hmm saw what was happening well no
for this it's called medurna but yeah
[Laughter]
i'm five years old i'm sorry they saw
the writing on the wall
and they said crayon
it was finger painted as [ __ ]
the grass is green for boogers
you know now this woman looks [ __ ]
oh burshmersh astronaut jiff with gut
with astronaut jiff with gun
all right guys this is really serious
did they pick sarah cause she's one of
the passable retards no no they picked
her cause she was the she was the chick
on workaholics that work with them but
what i'm saying is what if modernity was
smart right they knew the [ __ ] vax
thing was going to start kind of
plateauing
so they invested all that profit into
yellow and blue balloons
and then they said we need to go to war
with ukraine yeah
and then we're like deal
done oh [ __ ] we've cornered the market
on blue yellow lights and balloons we're
gonna make another [ __ ] we're gonna
make another mint
golden state fans must be furious
you're like man the price of our
balloons have skyrocketed this is
ridiculous
everyone thinks when i'm wearing my
golden state jersey i'm supporting
ukraine god damn it
i thought this was your gate that was
just a gay pride jersey cops and
celebrate no that's the trigger
down syndrome and then we have a stage
oh they are panning we're going to see
the pan
over here um
interestingly enough socks
okay come on
how does this help down syndrome it
doesn't but justin trudeau right now is
so horny watching this
one of the
one of the symbols of down syndrome
because the chromosomes look like socks
so
so you're mocking the chromosome you do
hold on hold on do they get a pair
that's three of them instead of two yeah
they have an extra sock in each bag a
lot of people wear mismatched
socks on world down syndrome day so we
have two stations down here where they
can where are all the people one's a
shooting station the other is the
pissing station nothing decorates that's
the buckets in the corner over there
create their own socks for a special
little
craft project today and then inside we
have
a dj those are the ones she made
star wars i'll have you know for yes and
also have you know that there's a lot of
down syndrome waiting outside they're
just confused by the pull and push of
the door
just a line around the block there's no
handle and it says pull people with
[ __ ] giant tongues and sunken eyes
just lined up around the block
[Music]
people they're all going up to the front
desk asking for directions like when the
party and they're like sir i'm afraid i
can't let you in here you're [ __ ]
that's actually that's actually
that's a great premise for a show the
pooping dead
sir riot fest is that way you're right
if they're not even [ __ ] you're like
yeah edc is not till next week
party um
for most of the day so dean or dj over
there wow this looks like it [ __ ]
sucks no too kitty this is lit af family
indeed
bro
bro i'd be pissed if i had to go to this
if i was [ __ ]
you just
i'd be like even i have better things to
do today
you're right
all the all the w women have a bunch of
beads around them the downies because
the men are throwing beats out of
showing off to retar titties you're
right and the retards are like i get
better things to do i gotta watch a show
of my people sunday night [ __ ] show
take that frozen miss another day you
know what don't worry frozen i got your
back bud i can't stay up super late to
watch joy of petty
it's very funny i really like him
because i always talk over movies
watch this part
you know come on guys let's see what
megan mccain body here oh no [ __ ] dean
that's not fair she has a job
she's on tv
oh no what happened
our dj over there is setting up um
families will join us in about 15
minutes oh it sounds like a lot of fun
especially since you've missed it like
you said having to cancel it with the
pandemic talk about the dj plays the
cha-cha slide but half speed so it's
easier to follow
slide to wherever you want
slides wherever you want
hop if you want to i guess
chris cross
you know
poo poo real smooth now
enough
about how many minnesotans are living
with down syndrome and families three
that's a lot of fun really over plan the
party i'm not gonna lie to you it's
mostly it's just three down central
people and the rest are dnc donors dude
you play four thousand dollars a plate
for a plate of jelly beans and
starbursts oh [ __ ] the pessy bessie's
like wait how much how much is it four
g's this is a deconstructed uh
strawberry jelly belly with a uh
reduction gummy worm reduction you know
you know what the worst part about this
is is you know this [ __ ] goes on about
this for the other 364 days a year oh of
course yes this is her [ __ ] what did
i tell you about the shitty coffee this
is her wrestlemania that's the a.a
coffee yeah
it's a shitty tin coffee machine that by
the way has no insulation to it yeah so
they pour the coffee in it and you're
like oh it looks like it has insulin it
has none well you have coffee goes cold
within [ __ ] minutes you have fancy
french press this is a puerto rican
press well they have the little metal
thing down there now so what they do is
they would have put the fire below it
but since the downies don't know not to
touch
i always like how my coffee is burnt as
possible at the bottom that's my
favorite kind of but yeah but it has to
be the perfect combo of burnt and now
cold again yes yes like burnt in
lukewarm not even delicious lukewarm i
think that's worse
i'd like a warm cup of liquid burnt
toast please thank you we're out of
powdered creamer you know when we had
coconut i made like one of those like
really good cups of coffee in my house
and when i sipped it and i tasted
nothing i was like
oh my god it's the first time in my life
i've ever not tasted it it's weird right
and it was strong coffee and i was like
and it was warm water it was just hot
water i was drinking i was like oh
that's not good that's not good at all i
had a sprite
i had a sprite when i had coveted my
that's the first time it was my taste
was gone i went
and i look i honestly looked to see if
it got bad it tasted like chemicals
because i was only tasting the chemicals
and like not the sprite yeah it was the
worst
you were like it tastes like calories
gonna go yeah cause you were drinking
chemicals i was but at least you taste
the lemon lime
at least it was sweet chemicals
royce looked at it to make sure he
wasn't drinking a seltzer like wait do
we have club soda in the house why do we
have that that's a la croix
pacted and how the association helps
those families
sure so there's about 4 200 minnesotans
with down syndrome
and
they're called congress am i right
and down syndrome as you mentioned
before is the third copy of the 21st
chromosome which does impact
developmental disabilities um and and
those types of things so you have it
because her mouth is very slanty no no
no no she's a big fan of either
sylvester stallone or that dude from
heroes
what that dude from by the way who also
played sylvester stallone's son in in
one of the rocky films
do you should exist first
family vintage
that's the one
guys
we gotta let jim ross mouth finish yeah
that's right all right
it's tuesday night and you know what
that means it's tuesday night you know
what that means tony we got a bunch of
retards gathered in a sheridan
conference room so it's a normal
dynamite aw dynamite that's
[Laughter]
i refuse
i refuse can i just say something sure
lakers fan [ __ ] gross what a [ __ ]
he's a lakers he's a vikings fan that's
vikings oh yeah or whatever well again
what a [ __ ] merch you thought it was
the lakers what a [ __ ]
but not you he looks like you know what
he looks like michael rappaport with
progeria
writers employers out of the way broken
some botox
seriously seriously call don lemon he
knows a guy you have a lot of [ __ ]
crow's feet well crow's velcro shoes but
you get it about how best to include
people with down syndrome because people
with down syndrome are just like you and
i they want they want but they're not
just like that one i'm not looking man
let's let's stop the joking aside for a
second here i honestly do feel bad for
kids that have down syndrome and parents
that choose to raise them that's a
[ __ ] hard job and i get it but let's
not also
let's stop doing that whole thing
they're just they're not like you and i
if they did we wouldn't be having this
benefit you know
want to live go to school work play and
do all the things that um yes see i
don't want to play though that's the
problem is i don't
i don't come home and
[ __ ] sit and sit in a sandbox and
[ __ ] myself oh no but i'll be honest
with you with everything going on
play with trucks can we just do that bro
make car noises
yeah absolutely and we know the pandemic
has been so hard to sit down and watch
you know one of those movies that's made
for you like fast and furious and like
really just relax you know
transformers
not only made for you but starring a guy
like you
that's why we know at least four
thousand and two hundred people show up
to michael bay movies in minnesota i
like i like ben diesel he's relatable
and he's very good speaker i find i
always connect with him when he's in a
movie oh [ __ ] you sound like walt jr
that's actually very funny dad i i
want i wanted raging man crunch
[ __ ] hated that breaking fast oh my
god hold on
hold on
how do the parents tell which kid is
there okay that's really neat you're
[ __ ] idiots they have name tags yeah
come on man well what if they switch
name tags they give you a receipt like
dry cleaning no they're all cheap he's
got a good point though man down
syndrome people are like chinese like
it's just you know once there's like
three or four yeah
people are like slow down slow down i
don't i'm not going to remember
everybody's names yeah the room full of
chinese people won't aggressively try to
hug you i was going to say down syndrome
people are a lot like chinese which we
all agree none of them should be driving
but
that down syndrome people are also a lot
like chinese and that they always spit
on the ground oh that's a very good
point but only one of them does it on
purpose
they're also they're also like chinese
in which if you give them a duck they'll
stick a hook through and hang in the
window
on so many people you know for a variety
of different reasons but it's very dark
also especially for people with various
special needs including down syndrome
are you starting to see things improve
uh for folks and on the same breath you
know when you mean like are they less
[ __ ] no i don't understand that
question i'm gonna gather no i don't get
that what was that i think honestly the
money they're raising is mostly for like
you know the balloons and the coffee
and their parents who have to put up
with them and the repair bill for that
is the sheriff
jared in the conference center
also for getting the democratic party to
allow abortions at 25. that's correct
people are starting to get out to bigger
events and take masks off um
which is great because the masks never
fit them to begin with back to you susan
getting those specialty masks made was
ridiculous
and then trying to get them last minute
and blue and yellow was just impossible
yeah they honestly was just easier to
buy an audi car cover
that or is that you know just helping
these folks bigger picture what are your
thoughts around that
yeah so i mean the biggest thing was
getting their heads
um people back to school and back to
work and we're still seeing challenges
with getting people back to work mostly
mostly trying to get the school buses to
fight through the roving bands of
post-apocalyptic black people that are
setting auto zones on fire that's been a
challenge for us very difficult um
especially with it being the short bus
oh god well it can maneuver better
if you think about it a lot of jobs
well plus the short bus is better it can
be converted so you can have a door
gunner on it that's a good point yeah i
learned that from somebody in chicago
prior to the well door dumber in this
situation but yeah pandemic just haven't
come back
he's shooting in the bus he's run the
wrong way
continue to be a challenge for us um
schools for the most part
this woman
she's so boring can we get one of the
[ __ ] people people do have
additional medical complexities with
this don't give me anything she just
told me to go stand in the corner and
play with the play though a lot of
families more in a home more medical
complexity i'm [ __ ] but i also have
a tune thing
all right well i told you to stop eating
marbles look one of those is fixable if
every one of those things is fixable jf
kicks the door open i am here for the
speed
this dating like the right place dressed
like a [ __ ] dress like a guardian
angel
oh god that's great
you know the masking is a challenge we
are asking people to wear masks here
today that would be extremely slow
dating but yeah they don't have one on
to talk to you yeah um and we expect
yeah i'm sorry i won't be wearing a mask
to your event because i'm not [ __ ]
only a [ __ ] would wear a mask at this
point no even they don't they keep
taking them off that's not that wouldn't
work even though it doesn't work they
were taking them off during the
pandemics they're [ __ ] that would be
so great if she had said that yeah and i
honestly we are asking today that people
wear masks for this event because i'm
[ __ ]
um just because there is still some
concern with it is there yeah they're
retards
someday is about awareness but also
celebrating the uniqueness
i would catch cove that i want to die
guys celebrating the uniqueness of
having down syndrome i don't know like i
honestly would you ever would you rather
have a [ __ ] a down syndrome kid or a
kid who's gifted a piano
yeah hold on
is the gift to kid asian
i mean if he if you have a kid and he's
asian then that's kind of weird no like
an adopted kidnation like is he asian
why would you adopt a kid with down
syndrome see now you're killing me oh no
a nation
i wanted the asian with down syndrome
have you seen those
first of all calling those i don't think
is no no that's not what i'm
i don't think that's the right word
you said that like
like you were watching football this
weekend and like the steelers were
wearing the throwback jerseys and you're
like have you seen those they're
actually pretty tight i was gonna grab
one
there's two things i don't care about
down syndrome people in syrians
and i'm all out of syrians listen we're
here to celebrate the uniqueness of
having down syndrome and it's not a cope
because it's not like people that are
having that are expecting a baby don't
sit there and get on their knees and
pray to god every night that it doesn't
come out retired i mean of course
and if it is a possibility and they find
out early enough they'll just abort it
or they could start a podcast but i hate
this like fakeness like i understand
being nice raising money i'm not saying
you got to go be mean to [ __ ] people
i think he's implying that but what i
don't get is this like we all do this
weird fake cope where they're like how
great is it to have a special child and
it's like
dude let's be fair you you were pretty
upset at first there's no way that you
were like yay down
it's like going to [ __ ] it's like
going to the genetics crap table and
you're going to roll the dice and
somebody's like come on down syndrome
and you're like are you betting against
the table
are you betting the don't come line i
mean most people that do have kids with
down syndrome don't have a c-section
they have a plan b section oh no i'm
ruined
i'm ruined
one roll
shared with uh something i didn't eat
the steak it's not cooked right photos
from
sucking my own dick
and the smile what's gonna happen if
like one of dave rubin's kids comes out
downsea and then they're like now you
can keep it are you kidding me
first off those those kids are
genetically engineered well it's
engineered with dave rubin come come on
let's be real yeah so the kids can have
a receding hairline that's not a big
deal you could fix that now
what look at portnoy
what if it comes out gay though
oh no it's not going to come out gay but
i have a feeling yeah after some no he's
going to say it came out gay after some
events
probably will be mm-hmm i heard it's
paraded around the drag community what
if he has the two what if he has the two
kids right they both come out with down
syndrome and dave rubin's like you know
what mark dice was right
you can't take you can't just rip a
child from its mother's arms
has to be son of a [ __ ] mark dice has
to be right he sounds like somebody with
down syndrome oh yeah
he's the dark snowflake
you like that out that's stucky
no if you'll excuse me i got a whirled
down syndrome event to go down
take that matt welch
i actually like my dice i'll just you
know be up for fun we teased mark dice
on the show but we've always liked we
always like
hey you know who came out supporting him
and his his whole stance britney venti
oh you mean [ __ ] e.t in the wig yeah
i know no sloth from ice age same thing
kid
and those families faces i mean oh my
goodness you must be so excited to have
this opportunity back
we're so excited to be back slow news
day
it's a very slow news day to do a five
minute segment on this slow news day
slow news oh you [ __ ]
zeke is [ __ ] i know don't explain it
oh
together we really are this has been
this was the first thing we cancelled um
and we killed well no first we cancelled
white
males should have canceled all those
babies oh come on man
[Music]
mark dice was right about you
it you took a five minute segment and we
turned it into half an hour so it really
was a slow news day
the px in the chat it's just said dave
rubin baby farmer baby farmer so what do
you do for a living i'm a baby farmer oh
excuse me excuse me infant cultivation
thank you very much
get all mad
uh excuse me i went to school for this
and i'd like you to be called by my
proper title
oh [ __ ]
god damn let me see okay that woman
never lets you go through a single
[ __ ] day out to lunch without
reminding you how much she does for
retards yeah i know
she does it again now i'm gonna call you
out i don't think that's how she says it
well i know but that's not how much i do
for retards i don't know man you think
she's gotta get mad at them sometimes
she probably says some pretty mean [ __ ]
sure i'm almost certain she barely deals
with them one-on-one yeah you might be
able to have one
yeah she probably drives a [ __ ]
mercedes cl350
that's leased to the charity
uh
hey hey hey it's a company car yeah